um Professor luxcraft's introduction to
Adventure
for the benefit of tiny humans
welcome dear humans
who's ready for an adventure
me I am I want an adventure oh right all
right I've settled down I suspected you
might be eager oh we are
upload your Swanky purple beard no hush
um I'm glad you're eager for adventure
because there's more Adventure here in
the everything Factory than you would
know what to do with
all Adventures are the same of course
some are exciting some are mysterious
summer well silly of course they can be
dangerous too my advice would be to find
some fellow adventurers or friends if
you get scared they'll stand beside you
if you feel lost they'll help you find
your way and of course if things do get
silly
[Music]
there's no one else you'd rather have by
your side
isn't that right squint yours that is
right visitors
[Music]
yes well I don't know about you but all
this talk of Adventure has given me the
itch
and I don't mind telling you I intend to
scratch it
what sort of an adventure shall we have
what an excellent idea
foreign